Russian doll is a new Netflix original
series that showcases a girl reliving
the same day over and over
similar to Groundhog Day a Bandersnatch
source code and happy deathday there is
a lot to unpack from the show and it's
ending throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about Russian doll and the
meaning behind it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the show or its
ending and I highly suggest that you
turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to we follow Nadia a chain-smoking
software engineer who was forced to
relive her 36th birthday over and over
again this is a big birthday for Nadia
as she has finally reached the point in
which she's older than her mother ever
was but that doesn't mean that the
character has much more time than her
deceased parent Nadia is repeatedly
killed over and over again and sent back
to square one and similar to the video
games that the character creates she
must navigate the right path to make it
to the next point in the journey Nadia
is given the choice to retread the path
she's walked on before with an X go in a
different direction with a new flame and
fix her mistakes all whilst trying to
find her cat oatmeal eventually she
bumps into a man named Alan who like her
is reliving the same day whilst Nadia is
spiraling into a pit of despair
Alan has actually rejoicing in the time
loop because he knows what to expect the
two are complete opposites but their
shared experience brings them together
and makes them both come to the
realization that in order to escape the
loop they must first confront their past
traumas and use them to empower
themselves
Nadia must confront the psychological
damage that was dealt to her by her
mother and Alan must deal with the fact
that he actually initially died due to
suicide and both characters must write
these wrongs in order to progress yusho
states that we must break the endless
loops of our lives in order to go
forward outside of our own trappings
after coming to this realization the two
finally managed to break their loops and
progress forward towards the end of the
show Nadia discovers Alan completely
wasted and on the brink of killing
himself whereas Alan finds Nadia just
about to get hit by a car similar to how
she died in the first episode the two
must then convinced the other versions
of themselves to save each other and
this
breaks the timelines into two though
they are now in two separate timelines
the couples end up going off together
with one another and this showcases that
others who have been through trauma
though feeling alone can have shared
experiences with people in similar
situations that will eventually lead to
a support system in the homeless haircut
scene from earlier in the show we see
that Nadia has the opportunity to shed
the past and start anew and with Allen
at his side she will be able to in the
case of the homeless man she even goes
back to offer him support and this is
mirrored in her and Allen's experience
it's a really touching thing to take
from the show and demonstrates that
there are other alternatives from
spiraling out of control to the point of
losing your life because of it
it really showcases that in the end we
all need each other we are capable of
making choices both for the better and
worse but making the correct ones will
eventually lead to stability and
happiness in an interview with Thrillist
when discussing the ending natasha
Lyonne star and show creator stated i
think a joking way to put Russian doll
is that life is the sum of your
timelines
there are all these different versions
of you because even if they don't
physically happen in time travel in your
head you're still living that life where
you made the choices to marry that guy
it's always kind of lingering out there
you could have been a better or worse
person there are also other hints that
there are multiple versions of Nadia
walking around when she passes to people
possessing her distinctive red hair when
addressing this Lian said I'm kind of
interested to see what the fan theories
are to me it's more of an
impressionistic ending like I said there
are always a million yous walking around
it just depends on which one you come to
put on today it raises the question of
how many versions are there altogether
that's certainly something that was
considered in this video game sense it
presents a question of do they in fact
just enter a whole new sort of scenario
in that moment they kind of completed
that round
this is fascinating for me and I can't
wait to see how the show develops down
the line
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this and with the show being pitched
at three seasons what do you think could
happen in the future
comment below and let me know and if
you're feeling a bit like nadie then
rewatch this video and click the pop-up
links to take you on a new path with one
of my other videos this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]